rum roll please for the hellhound
double the frame rate that you can get
from a series x i think that
should i leave that in the video the
last few months has been crazy for new
graphics cards
and for the most part they've actually
all been pretty darn tasty
this is ultimately the reason why stock
has just been so few and far between
and pricing seems to be all over the
place they're so desirable they're very
good
and everyone wants one but is today the
day that everything changes
this is the latest release from amd it
is the 6700
xt it's the power color hellhound and
the reference that we have in house
i'm not sure that the performance and
feature set is
actually going to make it worth buying
over nvidia but that's something that
we're going to have to test
and test today in this video to give you
the answer after a short word from this
video sponsor
want to win some huge pc gaming goodies
asa predator is the official
global partner of intel xtreme masters
and they have some incredible deals for
anyone looking to up their pc battle
station
not only is there a huge giveaway to
enter but you can grab 12 months of free
xbox game pass
when buying selected products there's
plenty of desktops and laptops to pick
from
including the epic triton 500 so what
are you waiting for
enter the giveaway and grab your brand
new predator gaming rig
with that link down below we will be
focusing on the hellhound version here
today which i'm quite excited about
unboxing
but it is also worth noting that you at
least in theory should be able to get
hold
of a reference design and i do like what
amd have done with this card especially
on the front i think it's really nice
you've got this absolutely huge r that
someone said to me looks a little bit
like team rocket out of pokemon
i think once you've seen that it's
something you can't unsee in terms of
both thermals and acoustics this
actually performed very well
despite the fact that it is a two slot
two fan card around about 75 degrees
noise was pretty low it was audible but
it wasn't particularly loud which was
nice but for me i'm just not a huge fan
of the design because
if you put this in a vertical gpu mount
it looks pretty good but then you'd lose
pci generation 4 at least at the moment
so you're going to want to put this in
your top slot and then you have this big
red box that i just don't think looks
particularly great
unless you're going for an allred system
and even then it's probably not the
nicest thing
in the world but obviously it's up to
you if you can get this for a great
price then fantastic
but if you want something that is going
to be a little bit bigger and beefier
and hopefully looks better than maybe
you should consider
the hellhound this is an absolutely huge
box i'm expecting quite literally
big things from this i've used power
color cards before but i don't think
anything
this high-end quick install guide
essential
drum roll please for the hellhound
and this is definitely a little bit more
understated actually than i was
expecting it's called the hellhound
and you do actually have a hellhound on
the back of the graphics card which i
guess does give it that name but it's
not exactly the most crazy graphics card
i've ever seen
there's definitely some others out there
i mean frankly like the ones from msi
the strix from asus and what is it the
palette rgb
mess that you can get for the 3017 80.
that's a bit
more dramatic than this obviously you've
got three fans on the front so you'd
expect the thermal and acoustic
performance to be a little bit better
than reference
having said that though you do get two
8-pin power connections on the top of
this thing so you probably can overclock
it a little bit further
you've definitely got the power to do it
and hopefully the thermal headroom as
well you've got an led toggle switch if
you want to go into full blackout mode
but all in all it is a very
nice looking graphics card but probably
not the most crazy one that you'd expect
from a hellhound and then in terms of i
o you do have
three displayport 1.4s and then one hdmi
2.1
all of which will support 4k at 120
frames a second
you want to see something quite comical
check out the size comparison
between these two well i say beasts i
think one is
a lot more of a beast than the other you
will definitely need quite a large case
to be able to fit this in
if this doesn't have better thermals and
better acoustics i'm honestly going to
be quite angry so let's put that to the
test
shall we by grabbing our gpu making sure
that it does actually fit which it does
just about
this is the corsair 4000d we do have a
radiator at the front so it does sort of
go to show that while it is going to be
bigger than your motherboard
most modern cases you probably should be
okay amd quite literally put on the box
that this is targeted for 1440p gaming
but we are going to be doing some tests
at 4k as well just so you get a better
idea
of exactly what this thing is capable of
moment of truth
it didn't do anything for a second then
and i was like oh it really doesn't look
too bad i definitely think this is more
aimed at versatile gpu mounting because
all of that style was on the underside
i'm quite liking the default cyan
lighting it looks pretty mean
it does at least give you a fair bit of
glow underneath your graphics card if
you are using it
in this orientation and i absolutely
have to say that the hellhound logo with
the
illuminated eye really does look awesome
let's kick things off with some apex
legends because in the last video i
actually got complaints
that we weren't playing it so i
apologize here it is
and right off the bat even at 4k
resolution we're still getting very
playable frame rates
we're getting what's this around about
90 80 frames a second or so
so if you were playing like a 4k tv and
you did want to play this a bit more
casually
then clearly this would be a great
option don't forget that this graphics
card has 12 gigabytes of vram
which is pretty much the main advantage
that it has over most of the nvidia
cards the 30-70 the 30-60 ti both have
eight gigabytes
so while it's not going to matter in
most games to be honest with you if you
do want to play at higher resolutions
especially into the future this may well
come in handy don't forget that they are
marketing this as like a high-end 1440p
card though and here you can see we're
getting an absolutely massive increase
to the frame rates
anyway really between around about 130
and 180 frames a second
so there you go you got what you're
asked for you're apex legends
but now let's actually turn to thermals
acoustics and something that you should
be able to drive in 4k
something like forza horizon moment of
truth what are we going to get
around about 100 frames a second 115
frames a second at 4k that is not too
shabby whatsoever
i've been playing a lot of this actually
on series x and obviously that is 4k
60 frames a second so this is pretty
much double the frame rate
that you can get from a series x that's
very impressive and i will
also say that if you're using this with
like a 5000 series
amd cpu or soon to be 3000 once they
have actually uh
updated it then you will be able to use
smart access memory and forza is one of
those titles where you probably can get
an extra
five to fifteen percent extra
performance boost as well
not that you're really going to need it
when you're getting 115 frames a second
i love this game if you haven't played
it honestly it's well worth a download
you think i was sponsored by forza or
something i wish that they would
forza sponsor jokes aside it is actually
time to do some
thermal and acoustic testing remember we
do also have a 360 rad at the front
so this definitely isn't ideal despite
the mesh case
around about 65 degrees on the gpu
despite the fact that it's not exactly
ideal conditions
and noise levels well have a listen
are pretty much non-existent and this is
running pretty much flat out
98 99 gpu load i'm dead impressed
the question is though how much more
expensive is it going to be than the
reference design
is this going to be a super expensive
gpu that actually isn't worth going for
despite the advantages and thermals and
acoustics or is it going to be pretty
similar i think that
should i leave that in the video or does
that make me look
incompetent incompetent unsurprisingly
i've lost my trailer thought now but
what i was trying to say
is that if the price difference isn't
really that huge then clearly this is
going to be the way to go
but if this is one of those gpus that
they're asking for like an extra what
150 pounds just for a much better caller
then obviously it is not but i think
with a power color card that's probably
not gonna
get the strix or like the gaming x tax
at least we can hope
watch dogs legion it's the game that i
always test but no one plays
you know what would be a great game
marcus simulator 2021
you could be me for days at a time only
9.99 available on steam
one of the big advantages of having 12
gig of vram isn't a game like watchdogs
where you can see we are actually using
exactly 10 gigabytes
of vram this is 4k everything maxed out
with
ray tracing on ultra so even this still
isn't
really making full use of that 12
gigabytes of vram
but if you try and do this on a 30 70
then you can't because there isn't
enough vram
but and there's a big but you don't get
any form of dlss
with the amd graphics cards there is a
solution coming
in the future but until it's actually
widely adopted and in
a bunch of games you can't really
consider that as a viable option
and as you can see we are getting
anywhere between well
7 and 16 frames a second in that test
and obviously this is not a 4k
graphics card that's not what it's about
but if you were to actually turn
some of the settings down on the 30-70
so that you can get within that vram
budget so mainly the textures
then you can actually get around about
30 frames a second which yes
obviously isn't super playable you could
do it with a controller but it's not
what most people would choose
but it does go to show that there is a
big difference between
having dlss and not until amd can
actually sort of
get something that is comparable then in
titles like this
nvidia has a serious advantage you
really can see
just how difficult this game is to drive
as this is now 1440p
with ray tracing turned down to medium
and we're still only getting around
about 30 frames a second but obviously
you can turn ray tracing off maybe set
the
quality settings from ultra to high or
something like that but the point is if
you're paying all of this money for a
graphics card
that's not really something you're going
to want to do so that's all of your
live benchmarking out the way but now
it's time to actually get into the real
hard stuff and give you the figures
that will tell you whether you should be
buying this or something else
so it's time to hand you over to the one
the only
bench marcus afternoon everyone it is
actually quite a hot day here in
tasty great britain and it is time to
deliver you these results
and i'm actually still thinking that
there is a little bit more to give in
this graphics card
just because some games like horizon
zero dawn seem to actually be very
strong
it does outperform even the 30-70 in
certain tests
whereas in something like apex legends
something that i actually would honestly
expect this to do quite well in
well it doesn't even versus the 3060 ti
which of course should be
a cheaper graphics card so definitely
watch this space and see how the drivers
evolve over time
but in terms of the raw numbers there's
still not really anything to complain
about
i was a bit disappointed with the rtx
3060 because there was a big drop off in
performance and we're definitely not
seeing anything like that here today
but i guess i would expect this to be a
little bit closer to the 30-70 and this
is without taking into account dlss or
ray tracing
which is of course his own separate
issue so i'm not saying that you
shouldn't buy this because i think most
people would be
really happy with this i do think that
this is probably a little bit expensive
and there would normally be a bit of a
price war situation going on here
but i think amd are taking advantage of
the fact that that's not really the case
and perhaps charging a little bit more
than they should thank you benchmarkers
that was as insightful as always
but now it is time to actually properly
test the overclocking capabilities of
this graphics card
and i think there's gonna be a fair bit
of promise here let's navigate over to
the performance tab where we can
overclock in this amd software we go
over to tuning
except the very long warning saying that
if something breaks it's your fault
we increase the power limit to 15
i set the minimum frequency to 2582 and
i'll see if we can overclock this to
around about two thousand six hundred
and fifty eight
we're currently sitting at two thousand
five hundred i've managed to increase it
to two thousand
five hundred and seventy eight two
thousand six hundred and twenty two
megahertz
that is huge that is huge still no sign
of any crashes either
this actually does seem fairly stable
which honestly i'm surprised at
i think this software is a little bit
buggy at the moment because you can't
actually set the minimum frequency
any higher than 2700 and that isn't
actually what is reflected in game
anyway
so it does look like our fairly basic
overclocking tests
has actually capped out at around about
2 625 megahertz
the good news is that far cry 5 does at
least seem to be fairly stable in this
overclocked state i've not had any signs
of crashes or anything
and we are hitting 2630 megahertz so
that's definitely a boost
whilst maintaining actually very good
noise levels acoustics temperatures all
of that good stuff
so i think in conclusion if you're after
a 6700 xt
then the hellhound does come highly
recommended with a couple of caveats
the first one being do you actually want
a 6700 xt
because for the pricing that amd are
asking i think it's a little bit steep
to be honest with you
the 3060 ti is such a great graphics
card it's a jack of all trades really
and i think if i was going to recommend
like a well a blanket recommendation
that's what most people should go for
the 30 70 is going to be a better bet
in any of these ray tracing titles
really anything with the lss
so that leaves the 6700 xt for anyone
that just wants to play things that are
i guess very competitive
aren't really that fast about like
single player ray tracing probably
aren't going to turn it on anyway
but with more and more games actually
getting support for dlss
i think it's not necessarily a hard sell
but it is definitely a harder sell
than an nvidia graphics card right now
but the actual hellhound version itself
as long as the
price is fairly similar to the rest of
the pack
then it does come highly recommended
just be aware that it's not exactly the
best
looking card in the world but i suppose
the top of it is pretty cool
i would absolutely love to hear from you
on this one what do you make of the 6700
xt
do you think that amd shouldn't be
releasing graphics cards right now or is
it great that we've got i guess even
more to pick from in theory
smash that like button if you've enjoyed
this video it honestly helps out you
really wouldn't believe
get subscribed for more and if you do
want to see the full build guide
with the 6700 xt a reference then you
can find that in the end screen as well
if you're interested in current pricing
then you can find that as always
links in the description below and of
course while you're down there
don't forget to check out acer's awesome
giveaway and a huge special offer for pc
gamers
12 months of xbox game pass brings you
titles like halo
gears and forza straight to your
computer all with a tremendous power of
acer predator gaming pcs and laptops
you're going to be blown away with the
visuals and performance asa
are also giving away a 3 000 predator
gaming setup
and 100 codes for xbox game pass so
enter today for your chance to win
with that link down below thank you so
much for checking out this video i
really appreciate it
i'll see you in the next one
you